[Music]
Comcast discount shirtless bearded Oh
wasn't a guy he played in Mission
Impossible the guy with all the arrows
hey that's the journalist from wait you
followed the boring blueprint here with
the spin-off you have a badass assassin
on the run with a beautiful girl and
insane vehicle chase a crazy
hand-to-hand fight scene dickhead CIA
boss you didn't need to set your movie
during the end of ultimatum to create
extra ties to the Bourne universe in
case you confused it with Bethesda
Cameroon he's preparing an expose on
Jason Bourne Treadstone and blackbriar
Jesus now I know I had a spin-off movie
that's 2 hours and 15 minutes long
because it spends way too much time on
Bourne retread Stoney
we had born six weeks ago in Moscow he
was on foot wounded with a full Cossack
pasta's ass somehow he walked out of
there somehow wasn't Kramer actually in
the original trilogy
you were given a Ferrari and your people
treated it like a lawnmower you break it
you bought it does that even mean was
ever this it was ever bus
I mean you break it you bought it was
old enough on its own but it was ever
thus precedes video technology audio
recording technology and probably even
the written word for tonight's
performance of the grey the part of Liam
Neeson will be played by Jeremy Renner
we apologize for any inconvenience I'm
pretty sure this is just footage of Tony
Gilroy punishment of Edward Norton for
being Edward Norton oh good we finally
got that American History X reunion that
no one asked for I wonder who Edward
Furlong is playing in this thing
man movie spends a lot of the beginning
on this Alaskan expedition is he looking
for ghosts Kevin Costner up here bow
Lord of the Rings I want to know about
anybody who talked to anybody about
anything at any time
Facebook Jesus Christ that needles huge
he's not drawing blood he's pulling up
bone marrow is there a location on earth
that we haven't visited in the first
eight minutes of this movie Jeremy yes
exposition by multiple news broadcasts
but also exposition the fans of the
Bourne films already know okay guys we
got the shot so you don't need to
continue the camera rotation guys guys I
mean he ends up at a cabin and then they
shoot a missile at him and he leaves the
snowy Tundra for good does it really
need to be some huge dude bro
thrill-seeking k2 adventure before that
Kenny just arrived at the cabin without
me having to watch cliffhanger first
after appearing with him in Mission
Impossible Jeremy Renner caught a nasty
case of a Tom Cruise flu Frodo learned
bass by watching Gandalf play violin
would you find this YouTube now did any
Coke or adidas hands run
that video because if so we need to let
those brands know that their ads are
appearing on videos with damning spy
community evidence or even better the
CIA should just issue a copyright claim
against the video and then YouTube would
take it down immediately and force the
uploader to prove it was fair use which
could take weeks or months during which
time the uploader receives no revenue
and in some cases no one sees the video
if this born mess exposes Treadstone
they will turn her she inside out
they'll be talking to hook up before we
even know what happened wait what now
person how many people even understand
this work let alone have the will to
pursue it IMDB tells me that the
director here was Tony Gilroy who wrote
a couple of the earlier Bourne movies
honestly this movie is totally enjoyable
and fine and the only reason it got a
negative reputation is that it didn't
have Matt Damon Jason Bourne the movie
has Matt Damon but is definitely worse
than this film so you figure it out I
wasn't expecting you so soon
why the hell is number three who's also
a super soldier out of breath from just
jumping down from a concrete there's
make sure you have enough guns and then
there's make sure everyone knows you
have enough guns I know you have some
extra Kim's here Chu Kim today Green own
way too much of this chem talk this
movie's policy is to never remain in a
single location for more than seven
minutes hey he's here Bourne is here in
New York
this guy got more screen time in this
spin-off than he did an ultimatum and no
that's not true but the fact that you
momentarily wondered if it were true
makes my point Jason Bourne is in
Manhattan confirmed
well we think he's in New York but we
couldn't pay him enough to actually be
in the movie how do you know that I'm
not evaluating you do you ever not care
are you reading me jeez does Oscar Isaac
think he has to do a Turing test in
every movie seriously it does Jason
being born seemed like the type of guy
that would carve his name into a shared
safe house I know this was probably done
before he was in Deep Cover but come the
gone in case you confused it with soul
text you know what there are so many of
these goddamn location titles that I'm
already tired of using that sin so I'll
just add five here and save everyone the
time
this is a reality show character
introduction walk up somehow stuck in a
major Hollywood motion picture oh I see
they kill all the operatives with that
poison that makes you briefly bleed out
of your nose
okay fine but what about all these from
dead bodies they don't think sever well
tone otherwise healthy young adults with
a v' in pillbox hanging from their neck
mind you will arouse any suspicion from
local authorities that think Ross
volunteered to take the nest as they
split up to investigate a weird noise
otherwise short movie nowhere Oscar
Isaac finds fame five years earlier in
the movie pivots to follow his character
they were lined up all the way to the
structure and then one decided to walk
somewhere because they did not know you
were lining up missiles these guys act
like this is the first time everyone
they wanted to drone missile didn't
stand completely still during the entire
attack that's awesome this movie is a
lot better than you probably remember
wait all the pills were vaporized but
the bottles were left largely intact it
caused the signal Saren cross I bet
there were five different takes of this
lady accidentally saying it's Jason
Bourne on the cutting room floor no one
will be seated during the Twilight
portion of the movie isn't this plan
needlessly complicated he had to build a
trap wait for the wolves to arrive hope
that one of them fell perfectly for the
ruse then wrestle the goddamn thing and
force-feed it like just leave it in the
supply shed or if it has to be in a
living being for some reason just leave
some food out for the wolf and let him
eat it that way
do you know what a Sin Eater is I was
like a Harry Potter villain we are
morally indefensible and absolutely
necessary movie steals the Daily Mirror
mantra of cinema sins and puts it in
character's mouth she was cooked a
minute she hitched her wagon to Jason
Bourne you mean at the very end of
ultimatum which this movie told me is
still going on right now while Erin
cross is up in the mountains that Bourne
the time lens definitely don't drive
here for Christ's sake she brought the
son of a bitch back to America fake news
at its best he came to America on his
own and after his own agenda Landy did
nothing to cost that this is Foyt's I'm
about to brutally murder all my
coworkers face wait so he ran out of
bullets and she chooses that moment to
what leave one probably insecure hiding
spot for a definitely even less secure
hiding spot I see she's his Julia Stiles
in case you confused it for the other
city that has a Sears Tower Bret the
hell off Willis tower stands wait how
did here and get all the way to Chicago
so fast he just left Alaska in that tiny
plane and there's no way that piece of
made it all the way to O'Hare this car
has been here how long this is downtown
Chicago not Nicaragua so in abandoned
car in a parking garage it's not forever
and I'm not aware of anyone on the
outside that is helping it so
basically the movie is saying he planted
this safe car here ages ago while still
in the good graces of the government and
no one has towed it or stolen it or
investigated it since he went rogue bull
did he expect why do you even take a
deep breath before opening this he's a
super soldier you think he hasn't
memorized how many pills were in that
thing god damn it shot pisses me off
because it's literally just for the
audience cross knows that empty this
house is condemned and haunted how did
the studio even get permission to film
here the ringing phone thankfully
interrupts what's a solid two minutes of
people preparing to go somewhere else
have you ever read your Employment
Security contract Facebook and genetics
I know how to read this seems like a lot
of exposition to go through and make a
single point about literacy projects
it's terracing defense projects that
could explain why he did what he did
yeah what about those projects I'm sure
one of those was used to make Boyd kill
everybody in the lab but the movie sure
does yada yada how that plan actually
worked
Jesus Christ I know they want to check
to make sure that Marta didn't talk to
anyone but they're also spending an
absurd amount of time in the scene
instead of actually killing her which is
you know what they came to do cross-sex
not gonna holy the way this movie's
edited makes paul greengrass look like
Stanley Kubrick evil chick sets down her
gun and scrounges around for nail weapon
supplies
I'm sure Aaron's deadly with a pistol
but the dude was also carrying a machine
gun right maybe even grab both Hawkeye
Parker work all the shots of this
asshole driving up to the burning house
only to get out and be useless
they wound him up and set him loose
Martin was literally floating this fight
brainwashing theory to Captain Marvel a
few minutes ago back at the house Rachel
Vice only agreed to do this movie if she
could scream 63% of her lines where is
it
Manila they have great envelopes they're
right
I understand Aaron's upset about getting
infected with the virus but he was just
lecturing Marta about the severity of
their predicament so is this the time
and place to have a protracted argument
in the middle of the fucking Road who
tells you that this is okay
I don't make policy basically every
White House spokesperson in history live
culture live virus I was honestly fine
with the borne see you sticking with
psychological training is the only real
tweak that made these super soldiers
great at killing beyond just regular
and giving this guy meds that enhances
abilities and viruses that he can take
so those enhance physical abilities
become permanent not a step in the right
direction you might as well have given
him a Magic Flute
you couldn't removed the orange cone
before filming this shot or the cone
supposed to be some kind of intentional
part of the shot that needs to be there
to convey the danger that's nearby for
these two fugitives you packing genetic
mutation infect the body and the Vectron
loads into the target cells
oh nothing more than a one-and-a-half
percent rise in your mitochondrial
protein uptake what'd you just say about
midi-chlorians it's not a boring movie
if the male protagonist doesn't have a
conversation with this female travelling
partner in a motel bathroom I can't keep
it together we won't make it well at
least in addition to the authorities
hunting you we now have a secondary
antagonist for you to barely defeat by
the end I for one am super stressed
about it okay we pan out from this
overhead shot of a cutout head shot
showing the elaborate coat hanger and
duct tape contraption he made to hold
this magnifying glass then we see him
pitch two wires press some putty into a
passport and how bad is his eyesight if
he needs a magnifying glass at all for
any of these tasks let alone one that
requires so much use one would construct
a rudimentary holder for it other than
paying off all that footage of the fake
passport construction when I go from the
u.s. to Manila via a u.s. airport why
not stealth boat that down to Cuba and
then fly wherever you want with little
to no questions asked
there's got to be satellite footage
there'll be plenty of weather imaging
but we're got to swing a little wider to
find something real time damn if there
was any time for a convenient zoom and
enhance cliche it's definitely now
Select Committee is investigating links
between a troubled CIA program known as
Treadstone and this man Jason Bourne man
this is the Bourne es Bourne movie they
never actually feature a Bourne
don't worry I'm sure you're Clark Kent
style disguise will throw everyone off
the trail weird that the Stan Lee cameo
here didn't even contain a line of
dialogue he spent all that time making
fake passports and couldn't also make
the fake employment IDs on the same go
he had to do that in a bathroom on an
overnight and overseas flight where
literally every other passenger is
asleep except his female partner she
took American 167 to Manila she landed
45 minutes ago look I know we're
supposed to suspend our disbelief about
the abilities of this shady government
at Norton agency but the fact that they
tracked Marta across the screen planet
this quickly with almost no information
is way too easy we interrupt this born
movie to show you the inner workings of
Willy Wonka's Phillipines Chocolate
Factory
okay enhancement juice is wearing off
right before climax of the movie cliche
mm-hmm
I just led to my own joke well someone
please in this movie for making me laugh
at my own joke like it
Carl D Brundage 13b I need supports to
have to clear the room
yeah but they're still working on
tracking Martin right couldn't fire have
a private conversation in the room where
he was just having a private
conversation
this highly-trained biochemist and
biologist neglects to use gloves while
handling whatever this is I don't care
if it holds the stem cells or the virus
or whatever abusive gloves the stems are
there she's gonna try a viral em out how
do these assholes know this I'm sure
they're generally informed about outcome
but they've been asking Ward about the
inside information this whole time
Jesus Christ has anyone ever actually
hit a vein in this movie also this works
I mean Marta said earlier that this was
only theoretically possible and even
though she knows the procedure this is
an incredibly short time for a perfectly
executed by rolling off literally murder
I'm gonna get my bag we gotta go she's
somehow shocked here either by the
violence he's so casually employees
again or by the fact that he killed so
casually again he can't get far if he
didn't viral out he's gonna run out of
brain its dialogue like this that
reminds you that this movie was directed
by the writer of modern classic at the
devil's advocate we just have to find
him fast and kill him can we talk about
larks no goddamnit you cannot talk about
fuckin larks whatever it is it's too
late in the game for this film to
casually introduce some villain or power
or utility a robocall you've known all
along but have simply refused to
implement until desperation struck save
that for the second movie like any
respectable spin-off film this one from
something I don't know about - something
on the drawing board and now you're
telling me it's up and running how a
music video soon's was born but the
sheep stomach cheesecloth thing on his
head it stayed home even though he's
already familiar with Erin's backstory
by our picks this time to watch an
expositional flashback why did they have
to send in the discount - they've
tracked these motherfuckers to the ends
of the earth and since they know Aaron's
incapacitated why not they continue the
desperate search themselves I know we're
supposed to have a fight between
badasses in a Bourne movie but this
makes no goddamn sense man I would
remove a hundred sins if after Aaron
wakes up from his coma he was suddenly
being played by Matt Damon
even though he's back to being a
cognitively enhanced super agent Aaron
cross doesn't think to look out the
window where there's an obvious
operation happening in plain sight I
want him to escape as much as you do I
swear
but this mishmash of exterior rebar is a
shameful bit of come up with something
for him to step on
escaping they may be lacking pursuit
skills but the Manila Police are
incredibly adept at pointing it's not a
born sequel if there is an aloof top
chase
except for this whistle this climactic
chase is just a Philippines ripoff of
the Moroccan rooftop chase an ultimatum
everybody this chase sequence should
feel boring but it's really just a
series of police pratfalls rooftop park
or a somehow omniscient pursuer and a
series of lucky than unlucky breaks gee
I need to watch all tomatoes as soon as
I'm done with this just to cleanse my
palate
does that thing matter right now despite
being intentionally run into thrice the
bus driver continues to drive I'm glad
they got away I'm rooting for them
actually but I'm a bit triggered by
motorcycles that straddle the line and
think they've created an entirely new
Lane just for them
huh I guess those are blood oranges now
capture and Treadstone operative gone
whoa hey it's the end of the movie let's
get the old born band back together for
an unnecessary curtain call yeah yeah
but Aaron was losing a lot of blood
like so much so that he was passing out
during the motorcycle chase you're
telling me that they had the proper
supplies in this fishing boat to get him
all fixed up
well all that's left to make this a
perfectly enjoyable but generic is hell
action-thriller is a generic ass spy
rock song to play over the end crit hey
right on cue I need your help
I can't tell you what it is you can
never ask me about it later and we're
gonna hurt some people was kamek an
attack son of a bitch
we're gonna eat it you would not believe
how much I spent in the generator system
but I keep getting failures every day do
you know why they happen no the system
was supposed to be bulletproof but
obviously the guys that installed it
something up holes exits service
stations every gas station residence
[Music]
this is the end we have to get ready are
you ready
[Music]
who said sans dead baby dead dead